the main finding of this study is that
people who owe a lot are 1830
drinks sometimes binge drinking those
people have a brain an
increased ability to consume acetate
acetate i acid which is found in
vinegar this in relation to people who
owe very little at all
when  if you drink alcohol
the liver then with green an alcohol in a
mentioned is that it is a process that starts
within minutes as the liver produces
more to cite everything it can use the
ethanol overflows in the blood and the blood
in the vein is the acetate to the brain and  it is for
the whole body but when it reaches the
brain it is mobilized the owners
possible damages of acetate in the brain are 13
in the short term
we know that the itaqui metabolism in the
liver promotes inflammation in the liver
but people who drink a lot
chronically accumulate fat in the liver
as a consequence  and says it can lead to
resistance that's not through time it
can even cause a sufficient and tactic
as well as the brain metabolizes also a
acetate can also be inflammatory in the
brain which is something we need to
investigate another risk comes from glycemia
now imagine a person who goes a
day or two without eating or eating
enough or enough and then
starts drinking alcohol in that
person within minutes of cozzi  it can
fall
as energy from the brain's energy
depends almost entirely on glucose if it
is alcohol it can yield acetate that serves
as fuel
the person can extract energy from that
acetate in the brain
the brain will learn that acetate
yields energy and the person will not even be
aware of the process
another danger in relation to aice armadillo is
that the oxy process of the oaci tatu
generates adenosine which is a chemical
that gives sleep that activates as those who drink a
lot have in their brains twice the
capacity of the ability to consume
to oxidize acetate most likely
is producing more adenosine
than the one who owes little, the brain
can adapt to that action of no de
adenosine in those who
become addicted will get used to the elevation of 12 in and
when they stop taking it when they decide
to stop even as a baby they will go through the
symptoms the symptoms of
alcohol withdrawal is more acetate can remain
high 24 hours after that last
drink
hence it is also true not only of
the alcohol sale stone but of
the acetate adenosine stone our
results imply the following for
toxic cation as those who are dependent on
alcohol have probably to be treated to the
consul of acetate in the brain and when ceasing
to  drinking
the acetate goes away there is a desire
to take to recover the alcohol and
recover the acetate the possibility
that acetate can get to be a
treatment for the initial period of
abstinence from alcohol nothing goes at all
is not making the process really easy
but  maybe we can help people
who decide to add to some
treatment related acetate the other
measures that are already used does not suggest  what do
we take a liter of vinegar
to support the publication date because it
could be dangerous but yes this is a
research trajectory that we need to
investigate and we will follow this this
we observe a benefit we need a
practical economic safe way to
deliver it  the proportionate